hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another em nice
accustomed story this one called
a coward's debt your name is Sean you
are 42 years old you live alone with
your wife Evangeline in your French
estate these are the only things you
know for sure you awaken in your home
with no memories of the past few weeks
your wife is nowhere to be found through
the windows you can only see inky
blackness what's more you can hear
something stalking the hallways of your
home and it's getting closer
now this game was made by the same
creator of amnesia the great work which
was just a fantastic custom story that I
played a while ago I think over a year
ago by now I'm not to be confused with
the things in the night which is also
another great custom story but a very
long when the the gray work took it all
I'm sorry what did I do
ahh did I shoot someone who did so much
of me oh I'm gonna guess that I got shot
since my vision is sideways here am I
gonna be waking up in a daze is that why
I forgot everything I'm like Wolverine I
got shot through my adamantium brain and
Lygia a coward that okay just in case
everyone forgot the title that I just
said so anyway um the great work was a
fantastic custom story for a few reasons
because it had quadruple distilled
whiskey very good this guy's a drinker
because it had um custom monsters
actually two new monsters that the
creator added and this one is no
exception scum will yes it did whose
voice is this whose voice is that
oh yeah maybe I don't feel uneasy
I'm here to good you must yet
is that a euphemism hmm hmm oh yeah I'll
go through the first second third floor
get to you okay anyway so the gray work
was a fantastic one because I had custom
monsters and this one also has one
custom monster the only difference being
this one isn't nearly as long I think
the creator's stated that it was about
over an hour's worth of gameplay I'm
looking for a key right now just in case
I'm an idiot and I overlooked it very
easily which I am want to do now for
some reason I can't open these drawers
but I think that's because there are
some assets in here there's a lot of
custom stuff that's gonna be going on in
this game but there's a lot of assets in
here that was unlocked anyway ah those
unlocked anyway sorry I have no idea
what the hell just happened there but
there's there is something going on in
this custom story and it is
exceptionally highly reviewed obviously
I haven't played too terribly many of
these custom stories because I feel like
amnesia has run its course a bit like
the Select slender has in a way but I
always look out for these really cool
ones that are very very interesting and
have unique features can excuse me um
like the last ones that I played were
destiny rebellion in a late-night drink
both of which are obviously in the
description below you can find them
easily and they had very very unique and
interesting features because they were
custom made and they have like Destiny's
rebellion was extremely quirky
especially in the beginning and had a
lot of like unique stylings that just
made it personal and very cool and Lena
drink is at the same time the most
frustrating custom story I've ever
played and the most amazing you should
see it that is the birthplace of tiny
box Tim the very first episode and I
miss them dearly and he may be making a
return very soon if you know what I mean
you probably don't know what I mean but
if you know what I mean then you know
what I mean anyway so that was a great
one and I I try to reserve these custom
stories to make sure that I only get the
extremely good ones for you guys to play
and this one is both highly reviewed and
made by a guy who is known for his
quality so if you want to see baby
markiplier play those games in the past
you can see the links in the description
below but obviously not right now
because your throat so enthralled by the
risen rhythmic lyric nice of my voice
awfully avi okay
cannot talk I swear I'm actually doing
something a little bit different hi
Alexander how are you doing today I'm
doing something a little bit different
with my recording in that I am
monitoring my own voice oh hello creepy
paintings and guns I love guns can I use
those guns on the monsters that I'm sure
that are gonna be trying to kill me no
that would be too intelligent
it's a glow coming from under there um
anything here no no no it's locked okay
hello is someone there okay yeah you
have a good day now you have a good day
I'm gonna go over this way but you have
a good day over there and insane ole and
I love this because the ambience is all
different picked up a matchbox is that
like tinderbox or is that something
different can i light that candle can i
light that candle with it what hey I'm
finally gonna get some weight to that
use it oh good I was worried that maybe
I needed that for something and it was
gonna be used but apparently this game
is actually smart innit a tinderbox er a
matchbox actually has enough to do more
than just one candle maybe the
intelligence of carrying a candle with
me is not lost on this gentleman here
you will you a note two new servants
Allah's French we take pride in the
cleanliness of a shutter and the
diminished visibility of staff on
premises premises
darling dinner parties counter can't do
that and other events the staff is
expected to stay out of the way and
outside so as not to interrupt
festivities hidden passengers have been
built into the walls to facilitate easy
and invisible travel throughout the
Chateau connecting the kitchen dining
hall ballroom servants quarters in back
hall secret mechanisms will allow you to
entrance you allow you entrance to these
passages something simple as such as
lighting and extinguished candle you
mean like this one which is why you just
gave me a matchbox Oh what do you know
that's dark and creepy I don't think I
want to go in there right away there's a
thingy here I'm gonna listen to this I'm
a southern French er a southern
Frenchman
an elevator that's a door I remember
this
I built this I built this door no not
even a little bit lady hi oh that's okay
I'm an idiot sorry everybody
I don't remember a fuel-cell lady but
apparently I need to find one so I
opened the secret passage which through
the incredibly hard puzzle that I bet a
lot of you are expecting me to fail and
now I go into the varied okay this is
really dark why is it so oh I get it I
need a fuel cell for here now this
obviously does have a lot of elements
from them okay I locked myself in here
hope there aren't any monsters I wanted
to power my bones ooh it is machine for
pigs in that there are a lot of secret
passageways like the behind the walls so
that the weirdo owner of the butcher
Manor the butcher pig Empire of
Awesomeness is unable or is able to
voyeuristically observe everyone in his
home especially in the bathroom areas
now I know that a lot of people may have
been disappointed with the machine for
pigs but there are a lot of cool
elements and I was hoping that some of
the custom okay it is so dark I am not
I'm not I'm not wrong here this is
incredibly stupidly dark oh oh that's
cool so there really are secret
passageways all throughout the game that
is awesome level design here well done
dude
I think the guys name is Damascus
actually oh good this is obviously with
this high piggy piggy I know you want to
be friends with me but please do not
interrupt me as I'm talking I am very
busy do I need to cut into your stomach
to find a key for sometimes I can't even
interact with much stuff here I don't
know why I'm a nice guy I want to play
with the piggy piggy piggies little
piggy yes yes little piggy play with me
any whoa what wait I saw oh okay is what
I put my hand on that but I didn't know
what that did did it do anything hey
never mind then oh by the way I don't
know if I ever finish my thought but I'm
actually doing something different with
how I'm recording this game I am
monitoring my own voice which means that
I can actually hear myself as I'm
talking which is a very important
feature that I have never incorporated
into my videos which means I know how
loud I am and what I sound like at all
times which is very important because I
can get excessively loud and the trouble
before I had was that I was trying to
hear myself over the game instead of
being able to hear myself and the game
at the same time which I'm able to do
right now which is a cool feature
because I can be immersed in the game
and keep a controlled level of my voice
I was in this weird feedback loop
sometimes where I would constantly be
getting louder and louder to try to hear
myself and so I think I like threw
myself off on certain recordings where
I'd just be like screaming non-stop and
that's what was destroyed
piano head why any particular reason no
okay another unmarked letter arrived
from Master Jean today I could not help
but remember how the color drained from
his face last time one arrived I know I
shouldn't have done it but my curiosity
got the better of me the letter was not
sealed so I looked at it while Master
Jean was away I was mortified for the
letter was filled with such furious
insults and violent threats that I was
honestly fearing for the Masters life
this man was clearly psychotic his messy
handwriting difficult to read in his
language almost gibberish I find it
beyond strange that Master Jean is not
contacted the authorities or even
mentioned the letters to his wife of
guests the letters are clearly taking an
emotional toll on him so why does he
continue to hide them because I'm gonna
guess this right now I'm crazy I'm
sending the letters to myself and the
lady on the recorder is actually my wife
who has been dead forever
and I'm also every servant in the game
oh I thought that was an ink bottle or a
boil bottle I haven't found my Lantern
yet I don't even know if they're gonna
give me one well
at least this one has good story and
good grammar that's something very
important these custom stories to me
it's so it's so amazing this but I like
not just on the inner in general how
people are like Oh grammar nazis
everywhere but I mean it's so amazing
how grammar can instantly take you out
of a story ok so I know what I need to
do I need to find there was a switch
without a handle right here so there's
got to be a place where there is a
handle that it can pick them put in
there and then I can open that door and
progress but that might take a while
because I'm dumb and I'm unable to solve
the simplest of puzzles most of the time
so how would anybody be expecting me
okay I just got that stuck so if there's
something under here I really hope not
because I'll never be able to find it
ever ever ever ever ever is that some no
that's a bottle of nothing good job me
you found a bottle of nothing oh wait
there's one more chest I didn't open
hello is there any levers in here
cool st. Avani Barney want to give their
friends out god I cannot do a French
accent to save my life oh it's in there
oh my god I looked through the whole
building over and over again looking for
this and I thought I I can't believe I
missed that holy crap it is the problem
because it is so exceptionally dark you
guys might be able to see because I
bumped up the brightness for you but for
some reason I've got the gamma in the
game loaded up like not all the way up
to ruin the atmosphere but oh all up
just enough so that I can see things and
yet is still not there wait a minute
where the hell am I where does where
this leave off oh hello is somebody in
here the ambience just shut off for no
reason I'm not very happy about that can
i light the fireplace maybe okay can I
use the side of his way I didn't I
wouldn't think so that would be only
logical lighting a fire would only lead
the monsters quickly leader to me so now
I just need to find something else
something like a key or something along
those lines it's locked there's so many
doors in this house that are locked okay
is that normal or is that something I
need to be worried about as a Southern
Frenchman I don't take too kindly turn
into that
okay who's playing over there are you
the guy that did the piano hit on me she
played a violin like an angel yes her
music uh-huh smile
we're so beautiful yeah I was gripped
the moment I saw you're talking about
your wife right
you better be not some misfit you can
hear me is this not a recording uh yes
no I don't know I'm not matter more than
anything where is she where is she here
here is she here in the mansion not
anymore
oh oh boy sorry
my head hurts there's a bullet through
it someone okay all right is that all
you got it's not the worst you're gonna
give me here huh you got shake the room
a little bit and scream inside my own
ears huh well it takes more than that to
scare the markiplier and you're gonna
find that I am one tough cookie when it
comes to horror games I played a lot we
had a lot of experience I know what's
going on how many pianos are in this
damn place so who wants to mess with me
there's gonna take more than that to
scare me you need to do a lot more good
job me I'm the expert at pool I'm a
hustler of sorts I know that something's
gonna pop out of me it's just a matter
of when at this point hello anybody God
for a short game it's at quite a long
intro it's okay Oh
okay Evangeline Evangeline I don't know
how to pronounce your name I'm not
French whose are you screaming darling I
need to get up to the third floor and
apparently taking the stairs isn't good
enough actually this looks a lot like
the area from the machine for pigs
almost exactly hmm this is where the
intro sequence started when I thought
about my kids way too much even though I
happened to kill him ah go into the
second floor maybe I'll find tiny bugs
Tim there I know I'm taking this game
rather slowly but I'm I'm just trying to
inch my way through without causing too
much trouble hello the music got a
little bit sinister that does not bode
well for me I don't do well with
sinister hello I need to go to the third
floor if anyone could give me like a
lamp or a flashlight or a glow stick so
I can start a rave yeah anybody God why
these halls pitch-black hello creepy
kids are you my sons and daughters did I
murder you I don't quite recall I'm just
a deranged maniac who lives inside my
own mind oh there's the elevator that
goes up to the second floor so that's
handy-dandy
I also found these candles will
extinguish themselves after a while if
you don't if you don't keep relighting
them wondering what a ghost tegu is
actually gonna pop out at me hello it's
like a murder mystery I'd love it
I don't love it
eleven when a game actually has a story
that can engross you cuz that's the most
important thing in horror games I've
found you know besides the general
appearance of horror games in terms of
like music and atmosphere and all that
jazz
what's really important about a horror
game that a lot of people overlook is a
great story it needs to have something
that makes the player committed to the
game as opposed to just being a ooh
here's a monster oh here's a jump-scare
please don't tell me I have to look
through these bookshelves but I mean if
there's a story then there's a reason
for a player to stay connected to the
game and there isn't just this
alienation factor of oh I'm playing as
someone else oh I'm actually someone
that's what people need to think and
that's what I need to think as I play
this game
oh okay was locked nevermind mmm God why
am I gonna stop coming across locked
door and I'm actually gonna go somewhere
I think there's got to be another place
that I need to go in terms of a secret
alleyway or something but every door I
come across is locked god Dinges damn it
all this looks good this is the bathroom
the bathroom of nightmares
flush nobody anybody is someone voyeur
in me through the window the walls that
the sweat drop down my forehead
can this get to a nope all right then
geez I seriously have no idea what's
going on here
I keep getting run around in circles I
haven't actually done anything besides
going up to the second floor and solving
some simple puzzles that shouldn't have
taken me nearly as long as they did I am
at a loss for where I'm supposed to go
someone dropped their bottle of blood
okay flashback time how could you do
this to me I don't know my project is
that me I'm the one that perfected the
formula I deserve these have the money
okay
we even said you couldn't have done it
without me right mmm I liked I've always
hated okay that's the same guy who's
playing me I don't really recall hmm oh
hello someone there is it time is this
when the monsters come out to play I
don't know you're gonna have to tell me
a bit more I think I'm finally starting
to get into it so maybe there's gonna be
you hello is that what is this oh I know
what this goes I know exactly where this
goes I saw it there was another side
that was like the dinner plate things I
know let me check the rest of the room I
know exactly where that goes I'm
actually excited because I'm actually
solving a puzzle right away instead of
being a looky-loo and going around in
circles over and over and not being able
to solve anything
but now I can because I'm super duper
duper smart did I go this way um maybe
maybe this is the way I went oh god I'm
going in circles now okay that was the
bathroom in nightmares so then I must
have gone this way hello boy okay that's
a wall that is nothing that's a wall I'm
an idiot so there's got to be a way that
I can go back I can hardly tell coz it's
so damn dark why is it always so dark
okay Punk okay Oh sue they're over nose
ah here it is
got it got it got to get e oh thank you
thank you very much no it's not locked
there we go now I'm getting somewhere
now I can progress maybe if you're gonna
be nice to me maybe I can hello is
someone there that's locked too
everything is locked he's always gonna
be locked da fuels l-o Chemical number
two that's not a fuel cell dink talk to
me baby yes I'm sorry who are you
yeah what's going on here where is the
pencil lead I don't know Evangeline okay
thanks babe not even a little bit I
don't remember why can't I remember cuz
you're dead yeah me and my giant brain
already solved your little puzzle so I'm
just gonna continue on without the
condescending attitude lady I know what
I'm doing I'm a bit of an expert in
terms of an knees or things thank you
very much there's chemicals here god
damn it it couldn't be that easy they
couldn't all be here because gosh dang
is damn it no
wrong I was a sound of failure on my
part so I need to go back and I need go
through all the locked doors all again
trying to find another chemical so that
I can find the correct path to the exit
okay that was this ad okay sorry sorry
sorry
all right I'm gonna tried it like I
don't know if I said it before I may
have but I may have forgotten about it
again I'm gonna try to get this all done
in three episodes here because I'm
actually prepping to leave because my
best friend Bob is getting married he's
getting married on June 28th with yes
just happens to be my birthday and
there's a bachelor party this weekend so
I'm prepping videos to go there and then
whoever the one where I know okay it's
on there it's on there okay
boy I do not like that for two goddamn
seconds you go the hell away you go
he'll Wayne die I please hello there's
nothing there is it really something
there okay okay so this is when the game
is gonna go psycho bonkers on me I just
warned I heard something did you guys
not hear something okay alright I'll
play your game hmm
there was such a long period of warm-up
for the game to get involved in the
story I can't believe this game isn't
that long I was actually kind of hoping
for something a bit longer but oh well
so sad that is the way the world works
there a chemical hiding in with all this
wardrobe is there a monster hiding in
with all this wardrobe maybe maybe not
maybe I was supposed to hide in there
and I was about to die but you never
know with these things
it's actually really interesting to be
able to hear my own voice especially
when I'm when I have to get when I have
to when I get louder like that when I uh
anok just a little bit I don't
completely lose control of my bowels but
I just panic just a little bit I get
loud like I've been told by a lot of the
people that have done collabs with but
I'm impossibly loud like I just
basically when I'm sitting next to him I
scream in their ear for the entire time
that I'm recording and they just have to
deal with it and that's not fair to them
I should learn to control my excessively
loud voice if any one was at PAX East
they know this for a fact
anyway well bottle of booze don't mind
if I do
here's 20 years of God my past pursues
me like a starving
it's a letter from Guillaume with such
rage in Panama
the one of my mind
not sleep without seeing his face I
locked the compound in my safe threw the
key into the fire I know no other way to
bear it could have my sight
I'm afraid the speeds p.m. I have no
word so what a beta
afraid of magic Lansing these letters
I don't want her to see my shake wish to
be a decent man
okay glad you guys enjoyed that reading
of mine very dramatic I know there's
more guns that I could use to blow the
monster but if I am trapped inside my
own mind that is not gonna matter even a
little bit wait was it okay it was
touchable so that I could burn myself
I'm super smart thank you everybody who
saw that congratulations you're smarter
than me I stuck my hand directly in the
fire and didn't expect anything
otherwise to turn up okay those are
locked off super seriously I know a lot
of people think that I rushed through
these games but obviously if they could
see me playing right now which you can
obviously I'm not very much rushing
through this because there's a lot of
elements that I'm what oh excuse me need
to go through here okay maybe I didn't
because have I been in here I can hardly
tell what rooms I've been in because
it's so damn dark why didn't you give me
a ding dong damn lantern I don't even
want to go in them oh wait there's a
candle there I coulda lit so why do I
have an empty bottle I need to go find
some sort of chemical depository so that
I can fill up this bottle but where oh
where would such a thing be and I was
locked okay so nothing in this area I
think I need to backtrack a bit more
there's so much on the second floor that
I haven't seen there was also the
entryway of the first floor and the
doorway leading to the second floor that
I didn't go in because I just kind of
went through the door to the second one
now I am well and truly lost if anyone
thinks that I prepare for these things
in any way you are very wrong I'm
guessing what I need to do is I need to
fill up this bottle with the third
chemical in that mixture machine and
then stick it in so that the other ones
can mix and create the fuel cell I'm
guessing but I don't know what I need to
do with this I don't know where I need
to go with this
sighs just backtracking until I find
some sort of method but either way that
is gonna have to wait until the next
episode thank you all so much for
watching I hope you are enjoying this
custom story it's very involved I know a
lot of people were asking for more of a
story driven experience and I'm hoping
this that this can deliver on that
promise so either way thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
and remember in the description there's
a ton of customs
and I played in the past and as always I
will see you in next video bye
are definitely having some
Oh
I got dialogue really
to begun
I know
jelly
oh they're back
go
and so except so